[Musica]
salve you vi parlerò della sfida delle
sfide la morte
vi ricordate la prima volta in cui vi
siete chieste ho chiesti che ne è di chi
muore io me lo ricordo benissimo ero una
bambina non andava ancora a scuola
quando ebbe la sventura di guardare un
documentario alla televisione
fate attenzione a cosa guardano alla
televisione bambini e vidi un bellissimo
documentario che descriveva in maniera
eccezionalmente dettagliata che cosa
succedeva ai nobili nel 1789 durante la
rivoluzione francese
fino a quel momento la mia mamma mi
aveva detto che il mio micetto morto
travolto sulla strada volare in cielo
quindi io immaginai che la morte
comportasse la crescita delle ali
immaginavo il mio micetto volante sereno
perché piglio automobili in cielo non ne
ho mai viste volare e quindi ero
assolutamente serena fino a quando venne
descritto che è appunto i nobili
venivano decapitati mi nacque un
problema è questi quando vanno in cielo
avranno le ali malatesta ricresce anche
quella uguale diversa possono pensare
senza testa è la questione per me era
diventata ormai una questione
estremamente importante e comincia a
interrogare la mamma al papà
le insegnanti a scuola comincia
interrogare catechiste sicuramente loro
lo sanno hanno a che fare con diglio
quindi tutti mi diceva ma anche problemi
ti stai facendo
vai a giocare pensando ai compiti
insomma mi indigna a questa ignoranza
diffusa su questo tema così ricordata
mente importante tant'è che cominciai a
leggere troverò chi ha studiato il
problema lo troverò e invece non trovavo
i libri i libri fino que stioni
crescevano cercavo di capire sempre di
più leggevo sempre di buio finalmente
in the la divina commedia qualcuno che
il problema se il rapposto dante peggio
della rivoluzione francese veramente
allora dissi l'anima e la soluzione ma è
però allora se è l'anima cioè quella
roba diversa dal corpo e come faceva il
conte ugolino a mangiare la il cranio la
testa del l'arcivescovo ruggeri no
evidentemente dante non parlava del dopo
la morte ma di quello che vedeva
realmente nella realtà dei corpi della
politica del tempo allora decisi di fare
una ricerca all'interno di me stessa
cominciai con la meditazione con la tua
cosi uri gellar o io adesso con la mente
piegherò questo niente sedute spiritiche
infinite nulla nessuna anima ma voi
avete provato a cercare l'anima in voi
stessi e poi ho cominciato a studiare
psicologia canina anima si che si che
mente mente il cervello quando muore
finisce nella barra muore la persona
fermi che cosa credete che significhi
finire nella bara significa credere
e se vi chiedete che cosa pensate che
sia la morte lo so che siete preparati e
scusate lo so che non sapete che cosa
significhi finire nella bara non vi
siete mai posti probabilmente in maniera
sistematica il problema così credete di
sapere che cosa significa morire e che
cosa significa annientarsi dentro questa
cosa qui siete convinti
e allora che cosa accade siccome siamo
convinti di saperlo basta sappiamo
l'inevitabile cosa ne parliamo a fare e
chi si pone il problema si pone
questioni inutili
intanto però questo silenzio ha creato
una congiura del silenzio quando ero
bambina mi chiedevo a scuola ma la
geografia storica
possibile che non ci sia uno scienziato
della morte che ci fa parlare di questa
cosa no non c'è com'è possibile
in più ha davanti
mi accorgo che la gente invece che di
parlare di queste cose
preferisce correre fare grande shopping
lavora lavoro da ora corre tempi
pienissimi una cosa pazzesca produce
vita siamo bravissimi facciamo sempre di
più
e pensate nel mezzo del cammin di nostra
vita per dante erano 25 anni per noi
sono 50 anni perché siamo convinti
lavorando lavorando lavorando prestante
pressanti che vivremo fino a 100 anni
senza fermarci mai mi raccomando
intanto accade qualcosa di drammatico
perché e quando i nostri amici i nostri
conoscenti si beccano la notizia
infausta lui non sappiamo cosa dire
perché siamo rifuti abituati che intorno
a questo momento non se ne parla intorno
a questo argomento si deve dire niente
così l'amico dice sia insomma cercato
cosa vuoi che sia oggi il cancro si
guarisce di sicuro e poi non ci facciamo
più vedere e sentire perché non sappiamo
cosa dire non sappiamo piangere con chi
ma neanche chi ammalato piange come se
le lacrime fossero acido muriatico per
non abbiamo neanche le parole per
sostituire quelle lacrime
ecco ecco questo perché all'interno di
ogni famiglia c'è sempre famiglia
allargata reti e parenti qualcuno che si
becca la notizia peggiore e in quel
momento tutti spariscono
c'è un sistema sanitario sempre più
umano che cerca di riempire con amicizia
umanità vicinanza
chi deve morire chi è molto ammalato
vuole avere presente la sua biografia i
suoi amici le sue conoscenze già
comincia a pensare come saluto come
perdono come dico voglio di essere
perdonato e se non ci sono le persone
intorno ma tanti medici bravissimo
malissimo e tanti infermieri bonino
libre ma non le persone della mia
biografia pensate tutto questo è normale
è normalissimo e questo l'hanno scoperto
pensate dei tra l'altro ci lavoro con
questi grandissimi ricercatori americani
in america hp ha capito abbastanza
presto il problema theron management
fiori cosa dice noi inconsciamente
rimuoviamo tutto ciò che ha a che fare
con la morte
tutti i nostri pensieri e quando
qualcosa corta che siamo mortali lo
rimuoviamo le mettiamo nell'inconscio
intanto l'inconscio logora e noi
diventiamo senza saperlo quando siamo
sottoposti a cui il messaggio che devi
morire qualcuno deve morire quindi
moriranno anche tu diventiamo
intransigenti facciamo appunto quelle
azioni spese infinite
lavoriamo come matti magari ci
arrabbiamo senza sapere perché la cosa
più drammatica che diventiamo dipendenti
da qual cosa beviamo mangiamo male
oppure diventano razzisti senza saperlo
perché dicono questi ricercatori che
hanno prodotto centinaia di violenza
empiriche perché perché intanto
nell'inconscio questo terrore lug ora ci
coinvolge ci condiziona nelle reazioni
della vita quotidiana bene che cos'è la
vetta education qualcosa che ci fa
pensare a questo qualcosa che ci fa
condividere ci restituisce un linguaggio
ma per noi per i nostri amici i nostri
genitori
i nostri conoscenti per le nostre reti
per fare comunità
quando arriva la peggiore ma non solo
quando arriva quella ma anche solo e
soltanto
per porsi il problema e rendersi conto
che non lo sappiamo che cosa crediamo di
sapere
non abbiamo la più pallida idea noi
dobbiamo neanche mai pensato
è il mio maestro ecco la risposta la mia
sfida mio grande maestro il filosofo
emanuele severino il filosofo
dell'eternità mi ha insegnato che una
cosa meravigliosa
l'uomo soffre per quel che crede di
essere
e si crede di essere immortale cioè
annienta bill e la sofferenza
inevitabile ciò che deve sapere l'uomo è
che siamo già da sempre e terni già da
sempre eterne vale a dire salvi e
nessuno ci può togliere l'eternità
però dobbiamo capire cosa vuol dire cosa
vuol dire eternità ecco la vostra sfida
grazie
[Applauso]